he's Jamal Murray the Denver Nuggets
guard game for had 34 points five
rebounds four assists leading all
scorers as they tie up that series two
games apiece
Jamal joining us do you watch Game of
Thrones Jamal I just got into it I'm at
season 3 right now so don't get--don't
giveaways okay notes no snow sport but
do teammates try to spoil it for you no
they're pretty good about it
I can't tell you the number of times
whenever I had coach Calipari on he
gushed about you and he kept saying hey
you got to keep an eye on this guy he's
and I said I look I love the way he
shoots I don't know how great he's gonna
be as a player in the NBA but I love his
form but Calipari would always bring you
up as if you were being forgotten I
guess when you're at Kentucky so he
should be your PR agent man he was
really good yeah that's my guy
always always boost me up always you
know believing in my my game and
bleeding my confidence in my game so
that's my guy but did he give you the
green light at Kentucky were you allowed
to shoot as much as you wanted I think
I'll having 20 points so I think I could
get a mic you got a day off today a
well-deserved day off what do you do man
just rest to sleep eat good watching
filmer for me I know it's a great win
but no we gotta be far wrong for avenge
now we got to take advantage of it and
win Game five so I didn't just immensely
refocus and be ready to come out in
front of our home crowd if somebody had
not seen Joe kitch play they'd never
seen him but you were going to describe
how he plays how would you do it I say
he plays with a very high IQ um we're
aware and just a guy that picks apart
defense with this vision
he's passing and you know his his
decision-making um ladies ones guys that
it's just so smart and
you know whether it's bathing a team
whether it's scoring every games kind of
different for him so he doesn't want
those guys that you play off of Ben and
uh you know I has a great feel and read
for the game
no offense here with this but what do
you think Joe could choose vertical leap
is but doesn't that make it even more
impressive like because I don't know if
he does anything physically he doesn't
even look like he's in shape I think he
got in shape after the four overtime
game against Portland he's in great
condition you know you know he's
fascinating though he's fascinating here
we're talking to Jamal Murray of the
Nuggets the scouting report on Damian
Lillard is what just pick him up Mayer
that's it half court you know you have
he's had a used game in the playoffs and
you know we just don't want him to start
getting off especially upon the home
crowd I've been here for so just just
make him see a crowd everywhere and no
locking down on on on his threes who's
the greatest Canadian basketball player
of all time
oh you were gonna say you okay I like
the confidence of course you're the best
Canadian basketball player of all time
yes okay
Fritzie would you bring in Steve Nash he
would like to talk to Jamal Murray did
you realize Nash won a couple MVPs yeah
I do
did you watch him growing up yeah sure
but did you care about it were you at
where your fan or were you a fan of
another team no I mean definitely a fan
yeah I uh I'm fascinated with the whole
Bruce Lee thing that you know the kung
fu and meditation and all of that is
this all true
that you're you're a huge fan of Bruce
Lee yes I'm just growing up you know
having a passion for the mental side of
things the mental aspect the mental
discipline toughness all those factors
that you know can help you in every way
to fight basket game in life whatever it
is so so I've meditating you know
telling me no through a lot are you a
black belt no I'm not I'm not like well
it takes that takes a lot a lot of time
do you want to be I mean are you that
into this sport I am in currently right
now into another sport and the playoffs
I got other things I'm gonna play right
now
okay well once you're done with
basketball then you're gonna have some
free time on your hand then you could
become a black belt sure yeah I mean
then you know but I love that whole
discipline and I also when I see guys
who were good at the line but good under
under pressure at the line then I feel
like there's some kind of you know
there's something mentally there strong
mentally when they go to the line
because you got to block out a lot of
stuff you're 18 for 18 I think from the
line in this series what do you think
about when you go to the free-throw line
I think that's the difference you know
you think absolutely nothing go online
and know no matter the times for noise
it's just how you think about it you
know everybody talks about our
experience in the playoffs and this and
that by the end it is basketball same
thing at the free-throw line um you know
you prepackaged thousand shots to make
those total one or two shots and you
know it just happened to be I had to
make six of them so that's what practice
for
anybody say anything the opposition when
you go to the line no I'm not focused on
that you know what there's am I not I'm
not I don't remember if I gave you ten
free throws blindfolded how many you
make it around my Wow maybe you do that
like the last game of your career we
blindfold you when you go to the line
Steve Nash never did that what do you
think other game is you know the games
going yeah okay plastic is that for
applies to them for horses something
okay
but but you know maybe we do then you're
up by like fifteen and they bring you in
and low cameo and then they blindfold
you nail a couple of free throws there
I think it'd be good hey congrats so far
and a great start to the career and uh
tied at two games apiece enjoy the day
off and we appreciate your time Jamaal
thank you appreciate them that's Jamaal
Murray for more Dan Patrick show tune in
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on VR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app